I came to this video playing van
nostrand yeah van nostrand name and Dan
no that's pretty much clear bethey the
sudden ever flex so he has his name he
doesn't have the name in the notes as
well it's very it's to be expected okay
Queens gambit with Bishop f4 is played
with b6 it's quite an interesting line
to get some some more unbalanced
position some lines here that are the
main lines form for black lead to a very
solid play but play where you can Carol
really win lots of games this is a bit
more a bit more a bit more unbalanced
typically leading to this IQ add to this
i QP if he takes with a bishop or
hanging pawns oh that's true and I
forgot about this possibility really
okay it still should be a slight edge
for white disposition and try to arrest
the bishop with before
you don't really want to play five in
this position and I'm threatening before
he does play five Wow okay feels like I
had this on the board in some other game
I still think that white should be here
should be excellent yet cannot believe
in that if I before this just Rican sir
tons of squares in the center d4 d5 and
and so on okay um Bishop f4 I guess or I
guess to f-for what is he doing here
Queen h5 the whole
there is some tactic here that's that's
clear absolutely clear night e 6 I guess
maybe 22 or taking a 96-hour taking a 96
there must be some technique this this
looks totally wrong this is set up all
kinds of stuff Hanks and so on so there
must be a tactic okay takes Bishop takes
this is just devastating a d7 Hanks I
guess night takes um here I can I can
decide what you doing both is good I can
also take with the rook here first maybe
this is even stronger than taking with
the bishop take with the rook first
should see eight maybe it can take this
piece you can take on f4 maybe this this
really gives them some some weird
counter play
just got this trip c 8 move wow maybe
this isn't as bad as I thought but here
night eggs either I have rook c8 I have
rook c8 that's very important he cannot
take twice on f4 because of lucozade
Rugare 48 and this should this is really
weird this is really important Roxy aid
I had still not totally clear but I can
our a for Hanks that's very important
efore Hanks so he does not really have
time for any any slow move where this
this is Sir start something okay should
I just take here and Roxy aid to
initiate all those trades at the Antica
the Mexican do is take on f2 king of one
and i will get F to eventually okay
let's do that this also seems to be the
simplest continuation
check check okay how do I get the pawn
now look to you 194 I can play we should
be three
so beef before
you want keep on 94 or something like
that as much less clear than I believed
to be d3 was also Bishop a three-time
morning oddly enough chicks that's not
winning amazingly
how weird is that why is white not
winning an ID 5 I should have played 95
and then before this would have picked
picked up the porn okay this was a much
much better I guess at least
really
95 and then be form maybe a three can
play a five I know I then before as snow
then I can play before it's 97 also in
the in the mix of course it's risky to
play for win here with no time it still
I'd like to try check cut the activity
in my favor which I ok it's little time
very obviously
check-check
oh my god don't I don't like my king
position there on the edge of the board
I really don't camp let the rook endgame
is normally cheesier to plod just
blundin the corner Ron okay yeah why
wasn't this winning I mean this is weird
I probably missed something after after
this this weird queen age five wide wide
must win the game definitely ok it is
winning and compounds play once night f
59 f 5 mm all night db5 that is six
looks very attractive but this this
seems seems even better yeah that is
strong definitely if he takes here up to
70 and white pieces are simply fantastic
Bishop see 897 k great position he force
week and so on let me check this this is
seems to also be clearly better but not
not winning cake stakes III only moves
and now come compounds to go look you
one oh yeah maybe based on the fact that
that I can do what I did anytime this
does not seem to be Jack does not seem
to be winning I look FC eight is
stronger check yeah of course to get the
get the king and quittin quick get into
the game and this is Sir it seems to be
equal due to the comp yeah probably as
enough counter play here with the king
yeah the way it went this is a clear
edge
with 95 yes as I I didn't see the movie
I only saw it sorry too late saw it here
I can also take now over ton k 95 and
here i get get to take this check and so
here white white is what is clearly
better well it was very complicated when
i'm glad that at the end of even didn't
know blues on time this would be
frustrating i mean this this is really
really really bad bad play d5 and deform
when we are when you go go here a5 is
totally enter totally totally enter
positional move it weakens d5 and after
after this even night f5 is in there
9555 this is really a unplayable
absolutely unplayable TX takes the x 2
eggs and night f5 is much more
convincing but 96 looks so attractive I
couldn't really resist playing that okay
thanks for watching